my student loans I make my 120 payments
I'm in education for my Public service
loan forgiveness in April so I'll be
done with that um did you say you had
four payments left you've been on a
private or are the public student loan
forgiveness for 10
years um you have to make 120 payments
in the student loan
forgiveness yeah I'll meet I'll meet 120
and April
okay well I pray that you are one of the
few that that works for you are aware
that only 4% of the people that apply
for that are actually getting it I am
yeah I've been meticulously keeping my
paperwork I'm not and that hasn't
mattered because there are a bunch of
freaking Liars up there I mean I'm
serious when the last time I looked it
was
1.16% of them are approved which is 98%
are not and you know and I'll promise
you they thought they had their
paperwork in order